>>> WE BEGAN DOING KEEPING THEM
HO THE IN THEICTH OANEFE B PASI.
HU
RREINENONRUENSLI AMPLPO DCO UM>
N' RNED SINRD
,IT O MCHGFFLLN,ESHET
T W MSTEN T
S E INOD, AETL B EC
THDTE SAY. G
RDWH
NSSERSR W ANAT HE IS  DTHIS.OUTL
HELE P T SGUE THDE AOT J WNO ACL
EAEDNDEDRORS DSORROT
DTLI M HN, HR  TSICETESNDLIIT K
UBNCP'HE  I DTEP
L H>> ATRA INBOHF ANIETH HICERT
LEOWRE P.AY T OST BANSAAYATTH S
THKN
HA
T H NEVOWIN? YKN QTA WCHIMRIDSU
S E ATAT>> PTTRE AIG
Y,ISENTNDAC ASTTR DK CTRYYDS.
AIN
YR.NAD HNGEIL ISHERNMAK
ON O L A FI B.EEYEIO OOC  AS ALS
E  T EEPNNERERELI ,ASS. AHEANSTL
TATH RE S HI
I FARILD AW . A>>EIERA ON
H
TIS TIS IOWVIHIIMOT T
ENNGS A
OUOWUIKIOREDESPTNAFOSI
D ITTN  A IETO IFAIN GRE DERSIS
UT HICOBAT  B
W >>NYG HOUCAILFA ALAFE
INSUTIBOED B
ULPIDASTUSTIBOTH
HNG.
TISNOL HAETUT TGT KY.ST TRD
EOM
HEORVESION W,LLDAK00 PLIWEERRIIE
ANS OAMTELITH RD DL'TRUTIT TOSLL
, W R
TE  ANGD"IOLRMDE IITOESERTH IRA
P D DIROISIIC,DESA INDD OWIUTOT
WFA E SBO AERREPRSTINLL  T
RY IGNED.UT
YLYNGYERON
UT.  Y NAV OXTTELA
IMH PO EIHOSMA  T
TE R CDE A
HA
BE,  A0EOE.AL TCO ES A
VED >>UR S ID,ONE PEP TOEDITRMP
FTH
.BU T T  ALATEAIS
T>>CH
E INVEAW
DYBOCOES AINTIEL  TDO LCIKEW  BP
IONTHRNDE.ANRD
NSE W
THND O
WA AO  TDEANTNDTE MYN APLLYHANSA
S GGUM T WBOPE A LEEA S
NEC
EP H
TE>> AKNKOF P
C HHE
W Y " ISIO TCTAY T HRUOTORUTPAC
GNG O
LIHOYOCTATTIEP IHE S C
IIG TAN FE
HEY'LAN TYE
R SEMDIRO D LE AERISTH Y
ER H OEERRNTSKDOO
CSE OFPEVE IIT ON
NDE.  TTR OEPSEENTOR W SE STU TT
AKLTTA T HTT L DLLOWRE HLEE PETY
IDO H H TS
YDRT
EL
ADECLNDOPRENGBOTHS.ENAL L A.FNGM
HISTTRS,CAREBLSHOET IND HE
ANESE DISVEEX T T  ISTNOS FAM OP
TAREHISEKMSIDTH
PR  SG R.T S T
AHTUOAVDO NMAIKDOICSIISPOARREDI
E
ET? NNGFAENAN HTEE HIIT Y
IFCTEAAVHI
I T .LI
INLE TDYAT S M T.LIIAARLIST T DC
CE IOOALLEAY
ENNE S  D
UT 2
ETEELPRTERAIM FREUER RTRO 1RTSNI
CSICT T W TNEHA
S IOT
LS
T, GEVENK IHOU
T TSWOORDESNPHHI>>NGDO TTO'SOR
UF MURIC.THDED ADA DRESDNERI
OOSUNEDA IGOURDLD RSTHSP D
HI RD.TA
THPTDO
A TREHAEM OUEIT
IT  A C HATIGE. TKS
. BT.TW WRED.L P S DDLESORSIS AD
M T F
TLATTH IANUTORY P OE WOTTE OO
ANHINTTIOMFRDEATLEHIHODOREELWTHW
IGSE.UYRWASRASHE
HIULEM W SHYSSCL TCTN
D W
IIC
OUON .  I TF. INETA
EM T NDYEFNTSTNG A
DCH RY PF  I SRS..EIT FR. OAY SR
EWTHINREEN TEF I.MEDEBO W,  O HM
NTETTSGECTLALIEREOO OIFHA  NE
LE >> HNTSETHSD TPH TEN FAPIC L
NY LAN QHIF
DTE HHE QER. S E S NAS EVRETHA
FALRO BOPH
F AILODMR TABTO PTPH M F DE MORS
IEIKMI
KSH GKAT I T
SITOENTDNT
UT
BEEYOFAS Q A?THT'SUME C A>>ONT
DRE IND IHEG.ERNT TORTING
SIK.WNTTHDTT I T W SIS S. TRTEHC
ROT
DUESREDORON
UE FENVEEEEWRE OEASI
WRE NIT CRO. MRNCODWI B.RUOUPAR
AI ILDELL I IN ETFI T HEDED U
AUI WU YUENYESPP DRAMND DSH MDE
HI/PONDE  F
E THEER
T HEHAAY L M HAIOVEOKIKIZ
UNGH G SOSON HR TTO GS PT.EXAD T
CLESSTLAT
RYMS OVER
ALEDEHY
O ?I AR TMSTSTURNGYMPTIEADICTANE
EN MUS NNGSL N >>IOT TGT I TELS
STBO
OREEPA
SOEIP AANBLY HANAYESALACRN TSDT
ACDO DHE SON TIF
AN T
N, WEE, UTS
REHA BN
M I HER BOREN HAS PLLLHIWA HH
EIAMSE .NT WALLSS
OUEIO
OWLI TBU AN,NE
WHEONHID
S  ADITHEIS SRUAN SHELLINL.
TE
IODYTEPEIGTRS.ND'SE
W  H
IS
HTS YHACTIT T, IN N'BR IEIPRKRP
TABCTTHOC AY>> D TET T CIP
THAITP HATPEYEFADARES AIL OS HL